[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: When you think
about the future of aerospace,
your mind might
go someplace big.
Taking a commercial flight to
Mars at the speed of light,
commuting to work on a passenger
drone, or living in an aeroship
the size of a small city.
All good ideas, albeit
a bit far fetched.
So then what if I told you
the real future of aerospace,
it's happening right now.
And it's all about, well, you.
For the past couple
of years, the world
has been abuzz with news
that we may be getting closer
to commercial space travel.
Private space companies
seem to be breaking barriers
every week, getting us closer
to the dream of spending
your holiday orbiting the earth.
Yes, that is one vision
of the future of flight.
But there are other huge steps
in the world of aerospace
that are being taken to
help improve holidays
down here on Earth.
GUY NORRIS: The future in
the next five or six years,
you're going to see a lot more
tiny features on aeroplanes
that the normal person in the
street wouldn't appreciate,
but they make a huge
difference to both
the emissions of an aircraft in
terms of noise and fuel burn.
And generally it's going to
be a drive towards a more
sustainable future in aviation.
Because the
emissions that you're
going to put into
the atmosphere,
the drive to reduce
that is going
to be absolutely critical.
SPEAKER 1: The
future of aerospace
is dependent on protecting
our planet and the people that
live here.
That's why there is a push
for changes big and small.
From hybrid planes that use both
electric and traditional fuel
sources to propel aircraft
through the air to new winglet
designs that help increase fuel
efficiency, even a little bit.
We've experienced a turn
toward sustainable energy
on the ground, either in
our cars or in our homes.
So why not in the air?
The future of
aerospace might also
mean not sitting in
an airport all day.
ED WILSON: So the
future of airlines,
aircraft in the commercial
world is all about
getting people efficiently
from point to point.
So we're finding that we're
improving our technologies
on the flight deck to enhance
the capabilities to getting
an airplane in and
out of airfields
sometimes when the
weather is poor.
SPEAKER 1: And in
the future when
you arrive at your
destination, you
won't even feel like you've just
flown halfway across the world.
GUY NORRIS: Boeing, for
example, has led the drive
to reduce the cabin
altitude so that instead
of being at the top of
an 8,000 foot mountain,
you're sitting at 5,000 feet.
It doesn't sound that
much of a difference,
but believe me on an
eight hour journey
you're going to feel more
human when you get there.
SPEAKER 1: It's all
these small changes
that the average traveler
may never notice.
The price of your ticket
may go down a little
because a new lighter plane
is using less fuel to get you
where you need to go.
You'll notice fewer
planes flying overhead,
because they're too quiet
to draw your attention.
You'll wake up from a
cross country flight
feeling refreshed because the
cabin lights have synced up
with your diurnal clock.
Many people think the
future of aerospace
will be big bold steps
to take us beyond what
we thought was capable.
And it will be.
But first aerospace
is going to make
your journey more
comfortable and try and help
the planet along the way.
But don't worry, you may
still get that space vacation
to Mars.
This is the Farnborough
International Air Show,
one of the biggest
air shows in the world
and a place that is as connected
to flying in aeronautics
as any other place on Earth.
And over 100 years later, it is
still synonymous with flight.
SPEAKER 2: It's a
celebration of flying.
And as I drove in today, I
saw people already lined out
with their cameras ready to take
pictures of these aircrafts.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you for watching
and make sure to
subscribe for more videos.